le Dr Gilbert Boucher,
président de l'Association
des spécialistes en médecine
d'urgence du Québec, également
urgentologue à l'Institut
de Cardiologie de Montréal.
Bonsoir, Dr Boucher.
- Bonjour, Mme Lacroix.
- Bon, vous avez un bon portrait
de la situation dans
les hôpitaux comme urgentologue,
mais aussi comme président
de l'association.
Dites-nous concrètement comment
ça se passe en ce moment.
Dr GILBERT BOUCHER, prés. Assoc.
spécialistes médecine urgence Qc
- Pas très bien, en fait.
Depuis 10 jours c'est vraiment
difficile dans les urgences.
Il y a un achalandage assez
monstre. On le sait,
la pandémie, on est en pleine
sixième vague. Ça fait à peu
près deux ou trois semaines
qu'on commence à manquer de
travailleurs. Pas seulement à
l'urgence, mais sur les étages.,
ça fait qu'il y a des lits de
plus de fermés. On a des
patients qui ne réussissent
pas à sortir des hôpitaux,
parce qu'on a pas de place pour
eux dans les lieux alternatifs.
Ce qui fait que les taux
d'occupation sont très,
très élevés en ce moment.
Hier encore, près de 15 %
des patients qui sont venus
dans nos urgences sont repartis
sans voir de médecin. Alors,
c'est vraiment pas facile.
On ne le voit pas beaucoup
sur le... on le voit pas quand
on va à l'épicerie, mais
je vous dirais qu'en ce moment,
dans les urgences, c'est très
difficile. Pas seulement à cause
du COVID, seulement
à cause de toutes les
consultations qui se passent.
- Oui c'est ça, et vous dites
"achalandage monstre", oui,
pour la COVID, mais il y a la
grippe aussi, le Dr Boileau
en parlait aujourd'hui, qui
se met de la partie. Qu'est-ce
que ça vient mettre, ça, comme
pression dans nos hôpitaux,
sur le système hospitalier?
- Alors, effectivement, c'est
une pression de plus. On en voit
plus dans la région de Québec
en ce moment. Chicoutimi
aussi sont sous pression.
Dans la région de Montréal,
c'est un petit peu un mélange
de tout. Il ne faut pas oublier
que le COVID, oui, c'est pas
des patients très malades,
mais ça met quand même de
la pression sur le système.
Les personnes qui sont un
petit peu faibles à la maison,
qui ont besoin d'aide,
quand ils attrapent la COVID,
c'est pas des gros problèmes
respiratoires, mais il faut
souvent les garder à l'hôpital
quelques jours. Ça, ça prend des
ressources. "M. Tout-le-monde",
on le sait, la santé mentale a
été difficile dans les derniers
mois. On le voit sortir,
les gens ont besoin, mais
il y a beaucoup de... nos salles
d'attente vraiment pleines en ce
moment, malheureusement.
- On n'avait pas besoin de ça,
la grippe qui s'ajoute à tout
ça, Dr Boucher. Et là, quand
on regarde les chiffres de
la pandémie, on franchit
à nouveau le cap des
hospitalisations, ce qu'on
n'avait pas vu depuis des
semaines, depuis la mi-février.
Dans la conférence de presse
aujourd'hui, le Dr Boileau a
mentionné que tous les outils
étaient mis en place, à son
avis, pour éviter une surcharge
du réseau. Est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec lui?
- La surcharge du réseau,
en ce moment, c'est vraiment
un ensemble de choses qui font
qu'on a beaucoup de gens à
l'urgence. C'est vraiment
difficile par rapport au fait
que nos salles d'attente sont
pleines, on manque de lits.
Souvent, même quand on a
le personnel, on n'a pas
de place pour s'occuper
des patients. Alors oui, ça va
être important en fin de
semaine, les gens ont besoin de
se voir, on le sait, mais si
vous êtes infecté, essayez de
rester un petit peu chez vous.
Dites-vous aussi que les gens
que vous rencontrez, est-ce que
vous voulez vraiment leur donner
ce virus-là? Il est quand même
très léger, mais pour les gens
qui l'ont eu, surtout si vous
êtes pas vacciné, ça peut être
quand même assez difficile.
On parle de 10 jours à la maison
sans travailler. Alors c'est pas
des choses faciles, mais en
ce moment, je vous dirais que
depuis 10 jours, c'est assez
difficile dans nos urgences.
Si les patients n'ont pas besoin
de venir, on vous demande de ne
pas vous présenter, parce que,
malheureusement, on prend
des fois la place des gens
qui ont vraiment besoin
de venir à l'urgence.
- Est-ce que vous craignez ça,
quand vous nous parlez des
réunions familiales qui sont
prévues en fin de semaine,
c'est la première grosse fête
sans directives vraiment.
À Noël et au jour de l'An,
il y en avait, des directives.
Est-ce que vous craignez que ça
ait des impacts importants dans
le réseau dans les semaines qui
vont suivre le dimanche de
Pâques?
- Ce n'est pas nécessairement
seulement par rapport à la
COVID, mais je vous dirais qu'il
y a une recrudescence de virus
depuis deux ou trois semaines.
On parle de l'influenza.
Ça fait quatre à six semaines
qu'il y a beaucoup de gastro.
Les centres pédiatriques sont
pleins, ça déborde.
- Ça revient et ça aussi.
- Oui, il va y avoir de la
contamination en fin de semaine,
c'est sûr. C'est sûr que le
personnel, on manque de gens
puis quand il y a quelqu'un qui
tombe malade, soit qu'on ferme
un lit ou soit qu'il y a
quelqu'un qu'il faut qu'il fasse
un double. Alors ce n'est
vraiment pas facile par rapport
à ça. Les gens, il faut garder
une certaine distanciation,
mais en ce moment, on a comme
une certaine recrudescence,
pas juste le COVID, mais il y a
beaucoup de virus dans nos
urgences.
- Un peu de tout, finalement,
ça se multiplie. On regardait
les chiffres tout à l'heure
du personnel soignant qui est
touché, près de 13 000 absents
dans le réseau. Est-ce qu'on
risque de se retrouver dans une
nouvelle situation de délestage?
Je pense à ceux qui attendent
des chirurgies depuis des mois,
voire des années, est-ce que
vous pensez qu'on va remonter
encore le niveau de délestage
dans nos hôpitaux?
- On espère pas. Nous, ce qu'on
voit depuis trois semaines,
c'est justement, la vague a
commencé, le personnel soignant
a été infecté. Ces gens-là
commencent à revenir déjà,
ça fait qu'on espère que ça
ne montera pas beaucoup plus
que 13 000. Mais effectivement,
ça met beaucoup de pression sur
le réseau. Puis encore là, on
sent les effets. Depuis une
semaine, près de 60 % de nos
lits dans les urgences sont pris
des hospitalisations. Ça, quand
on commence... Comme en fin de
semaine dernière, ça été très
difficile. Quand on a commencé
lundi matin, on savait que
la semaine allait être très,
très difficile. Puis en ce
moment, quand on commence
nos quarts de travail, on
regarde la salle de travail
puis on sait qu'on ne pourra
pas voir tous les patients qui y
sont, ça fait que c'est vraiment
difficile pour la population.
- Et dur pour le moral pour le
personnel soignant qui est en
place, aussi, de devoir dire
aux gens : on ne peut pas vous
voir, on n'a pas de place,
on n'a pas de personnel.
- Je ne vous cacherai pas qu'à
l'interne, il y a certains
médecins et infirmières, on se
sent un petit peu en bris de
service, parce qu'on sait qu'on
ne peut pas donner le service
requis à la population.
Puis le triage, ça dure
juste 3 à 5 minutes, alors
on espère pas faire d'erreur,
mais c'est extrêmement difficle
pour le personnel, puis comme
je vous le dis, à tous les
jours, il y a qui tombent au
combat. C'est un 10 jours qu'ils
sont obligés de pas rentrer
travailler, alors on met
l'épaule à la roue, mais c'est
pas facile. Nos salles
d'attente, il y en a beaucoup,
malheureusement, on demande même
aux gens qui sont des
accompagnateurs de quitter,
parce que les salles d'attente
sont trop pleines de gens. Ce
n'est pas facile en ce moment.
- Dr Gilbert Boucher, merci
d'avoir était là. Ça nous donne
une bonne idée de la situation
et ça nous rappelle à quel point
il faut continuer de faire
attention. Merci, Dr Boucher.
Au revoi